so one thing we've been talking about is
getting signatures biosignature techno
signatures about other planets maybe if
we're extremely lucky In Our Lifetime to
be able to meet
life forms
uh get evidence of living or dead life
forms on mars or the moons of Jupiter
and Saturn what about getting signals
from outer space Interstellar signals uh
what kind of what would those signals
potentially look like
uh that's a hard question to answer
because we are we essentially engaging
in Xeno psychology to some degree what
are the activities of another
civilization
a lot of that is in other words Xeno
psychology I apologies to interrupt mean
maybe I'm just fabricating that word
really but they're trying to guess at
the
um the machinations and motivations of
another intelligent being that was
completely evolutionary divorced from us
so it's like like you said EXO movies
it's exop psychology extra solar yeah
psychology yeah uh Alien psychology is
another way of maybe making it more
grounded but
um the it we we can't really guess at
their their motivations too well but we
can look at the sorts of behaviors we
engage in and at least look for them
um we're always guilty that when we look
for buyer signatures we're really
looking for and even when we look for
planets we're looking for templates of
earth when we look for biosignatures
we're looking for templates of
earth-based life when we look for
tetanus signatures we tend to be looking
for templates of our own behaviors or
extrapolations of our behaviors
um so we've there's a very long list of
tender signatures that people have
suggested we could look for the the
earliest ones were of course radio
beacons they were sort of project osma
that Frank Drake was involved in and
trying to look for radio signatures
which could either be
um just like blurting out high power
radio thing I was saying hey we're here
or could even have encoded within them
Galactic encyclopedias for us to unlock
which has always been the Allure of the
radio technique
um but there could also be unintentional
signatures
um for example you could have something
like the satellite system that we've
produced around the earth artificial
satellite system starlink type systems
we mentioned that you could detect the
glint of light across those satellites
as they orbit around the planet
um you could set to geostationary
satellite belt which would block out
some light as the planet transferred
across the star you could detect solar
panels potentially spectrally on the
surface of the planet heat island
effects New York is hotter than New York
state by a couple of degrees because the
heat island affected the city and so you
could thermally map different different
planets and detect these so there's a
large array of things that we do that we
can go out and hypothesize we could look
for and then on the furthest end of the
scale you have things which go far
beyond their capabilities such as warp
drive signatures which have been
proposed you get these bright flashes of
light or even gravitational wave
detections from ligo could be detected
um you could have Dyson spheres the idea
of covering it basically a star is
completely covered by some kind of
structure which collects all this all
the light from the Star to power the
civilization and that would be pretty
easily detectable to some degree because
you're you're transferring all of the
visible light thermodynamically it has
to be re-emitted so it come out as
infrared light so you have an incredibly
bright infrared star yet one that was
visibly not present at all and so there
would be a pretty intriguing signature
to look for but is there efforts to look
for something like that for a different
experience out there for with the strong
infrared signal that has been yeah that
has been and there's been uh I think in
the literature there was one with the
IRS satellite which is in for a
satellite they targeted I think of one
of a hundred thousand stars uh nearby
stars and found no convincing examples
of what looked like a Dyson Sphere star
and then Jason Wright and his team um
Extended this I think using wise which
is another info satellite
um to look around galaxies so could an
entire galaxy have been converted into
Dyson spheres or a significant fraction
of the Galaxy which is basically the uh
the kardashev type three right this is
the when you've basically mastered the
entire Galactic pool of resources and uh
again out of a hundred thousand nearby
galaxies there appears to be no
compelling examples of what looks like a
Dyson Galaxy if you want to call it that
um so that by no means uh proves that
they don't exist or don't happen but it
seems like it's an unusual behavior for
a civilization mission to get to that
stage of development and start
harvesting the entire Stellar output
unusual yes and I mean ligo is super
interesting with gravitational waves if
that kind of experiment could start
seeing some weirdness some weird signals
some that compare to the to the power of
the cosmic phenomena yeah yeah I mean
it's a whole new window to the universe
not just in terms of astrophysics but
potentially for tetanus signatures as
well I have to say with the with the
warp drives I am skeptical that warp
drives are possible because you have you
have kind of fundamental problem
relativity you can either really have
relativity faster than light travel or
causality you can only choose two of
those three things you really can't have
all three in a coherent Universe if you
have all three you basically end up with
the possibility of these kind of
temporal paradoxes and time loops and
grandfather paradoxes working therapy
pockets of causality something like that
like where there's uh like pockets of
consistent causality you could design it
in that way you could be you know if you
had a warp drive or a time machine
essentially you could be
um you know you can be very conscious
and careful of the way you use it so as
to not to cause paradoxes or just do it
in a local area or something but the
real fundamental problem is you always
have the ability to do it and so in a in
a vast Cosmic Universe if time machines
were all over the place uh that there's
too much risk of someone doing it right
of somebody having the option of
essentially breaking the universe with
it with this so this is a fundamental
problem Hawking has this chronology
protection conjecture where he said that
essentially that it's this just can't be
allowed because it breaks it breaks all
our laws of physics if time travel is
possible current laws of physics yes
correct yeah um and so we'd need to rip
at relativity I mean that's the point is
the current noise physics so you'd have
to rip up our current law of relativity
to make sense of how FTL could live in
that Universe because you can't have
relativity FTL and causality sit nice
and play nicely together
but we're currently don't have quantum
mechanics and relativity playing nice
together anyway so it's not like
everything is all a nice little fact
it's certainly not the full picture
there must be more to go yeah but
um so it's already ripped up so might as
well rip it up a little more
and then in the process actually try to
connect the two things because maybe in
the unification of uh of the standard
model and uh general relativity may be
their lies some kind of new wisdom about
of of about warp drive so by the way
warp drives is somehow messing with the
fabric
of the universe to be able to travel
faster than the speed of light yeah
you're basically bending space-time you
could also do it with a wormhole or
attack you know some of the hypothetical
FTR sets doesn't have to necessarily be
uh the Alki bear Drive the warp drive it
could be any faster than my system as
long as it travels super luminally it
will violate causality and presumably
that will be observable with ligo
uh potentially yeah potentially it
depends on I think you know the
properties of whatever the spacecraft is
um I mean one problem with warp drives
is there's all sorts of problems with
rock types but we're like the start of
that sentence one problem
there's just this one minor problem that
we have to get around but uh when it
arrives at its destination it basically
collects this vast uh this has like an
event horizon almost at the front of it
and so it collects all the collects all
this radiation at the front as it goes
and when it arrives all that radiation
gets dumped on its destination would
basically completely exterminate the
planet it arrives at
um that radiation is also incident
within the shell itself there's Hawking
radiation occurring within the shell
which is pretty dangerous
um and then you know it also has it
raises all sorts of exacerbations of the
Fermi Paradox of course as well so you
might be able to explain why we don't
see
um a Galactic Empire I mean even here
it's hard you might be able to explain
why we don't see a Galactic Empire if
everybody's limited to Voyager 2 rocket
speeds of like 20 kilometers per second
or something but it's a lot harder to
explain why we don't see the stars
populated by Galactic Empires
when warp drive is imminently possible
because it makes expansion so much more
trivial that um it it makes our life
harder there was there's some wonderful
simulation work being done out at
Rochester where they actually simulate
all the stars in the galaxy or a
fraction of them and they spawn a
civilization and one of them and they
let it spread out at sublight speeds and
actually the very mixing of the Stars
themselves because the stars are not
static they're in orbit of the galactic
center and they have crossing paths with
each other if you just have a range of
even like five light years and your
speed is of order of a few percent the
speed of light is the maximum you can
muster you can populate the entire
galaxy within something like a hundred
thousand to it about a million years or
so so in order a fraction of the
lifetime of the Galaxy itself and so
this raises some uh fairly serious
problems because if any civilization in
the entire history of the uni of the
Galaxy decide to do that them you know
either we shouldn't be here or we happen
to live in this kind of rare pocket
where they chose not to populate to and
so this is sometimes called fact a
heart's fact day
um as you know the fact a is that a
civilization is not here now an alien
civilization has not is not in present
occupation of the earth and that's
difficult to
resolve with the apparent ease at which
even a small extrapolation of our own
technology could potentially populate a
Galaxy in Far faster than Galactic
history
so to me by the way yeah the firmer
Paradox is truly a paradox for me but
I suspect that if alien visited Earth
I suspect if they do
um if they are everywhere I think
they're already here and we're too dumb
to see it
but leaving that aside
I think we should be able to in that
case have very strong
obvious signals when we look up at the
stars at the emanation of energy
required we would see we will see we'll
see some weirdness that like where these
are these kinds of stars and these are
these kinds of stars that are being
messed with like leveraging the nuclear
fusion of stars to do something useful
right the fact that we don't really see
that like maybe you can correct me
wouldn't we be able to if if there is
like alien civilizations running
galaxies wouldn't we see weirdnesses uh
from an astronomy perspective with the
with the way the stars are behaving yeah
I mean it depends exactly what they're
doing but I mean the Dyson Sphere
example is one that we already discussed
where a set of 100 000 nearby galaxies
find that they are not have all been
transformed into Dyson Sphere collectors
um you could also Imagine them doing
things like we write a paper like this
recently of starlifting where you can
extend the life of your Star by scooping
Mass off the star so you'd be you know
doing Stellar engineering essentially
um space if you're doing a huge amount
of asteroid mining uh you would have a
special signature because you're
basically filling the solar system with
dust by doing that there'd be debris
from that activity and so there are
some limits on this
um certainly we don't see
uh you know bright flashes which would
be you know one of these consequences
warp drives as I said is as they
decelerate they'd produce these bright
flashes of light we don't seem to see
evidence of those kind of things
um we don't see anything obvious around
the nearby stars or the stars that we've
served in detail beyond that that
indicate any kind of artificial
civilization the closest maybe we had
was boyajin star there was a lot of
interest in there was a star that was
just very peculiarly dipping in and out
his brightness and it was hypothesized
for a time that that may indeed be some
kind of dyson-like structure so maybe a
Dyson Sphere that's half built and so as
it comes in and out it's blocking out
huge swaths of the star it was very
difficult to explain it really with
um any kind of planet model at the time
um but an easier hypothesis that was
proposed was it could just be a large
number of comets or dust or something or
maybe a planet that had drawn broken
apart and as its fragments orbit around
it blocks out Starlight and it turned
out with subsequent observations of that
star which especially the amateur
astronomy Community made a big
contribution to as well
um that the the dips were chromatic
which was a a real important clue that
that probably wasn't a solid structure
then that was going around it it was
more likely to be dust dust is chromatic
but chromatic I mean it looks different
in different colors so it blocks out
more red light than blue light if it was
a solid structure
shouldn't do that it's it shouldn't be
it should be opaque right a solid metal
structure or something so that was one
of the clear indications and the the
behavior of in the way the light changed
or the dips changed across wavelengths
was fully consistent with the
expectations of what small particulates
would do
um and so that's that's very hard I mean
the real problem with
alien hunting
technical term this is this is the real
one problem yeah one problem with the
warp drive and the one problem with
alien hunting yes but well actually I'd
say there's three big problems for me
with any search for life which includes
UFOs or the way to fossils on Mars is
that aliens have three unique properties
as a hypothesis one is they have
essentially unbounded explanatory
capability so there's almost no
phenomena I can show you that you
couldn't explain with aliens to some
degree you could say well they aliens
just have some super high-tech uh way of
creating that illusion
um the second one would be unbounded
avoidance capacity so I might see a UFO
tomorrow or and then the next day and
then the next day and then predict I
should see it on Thursday at the end of
the week but then I don't see it but I
could always get out of that and say
well that's just because they chose not
to come here you know they have this
they can always avoid future
observations fairly easily
um if you survey an exoplanet for
biosignatures and you don't see oxygen
you don't see methane that doesn't mean
there's no one living there they could
always be either tricking their
atmosphere engineering it we actually
wrote a paper about that how you can use
lasers to hide your biosignatures as in
fact civilization
um or you could just be living
underground or underwater or something
where there's no bio signatures so you
can never really disprove this life on
another planet or another star it has
infinite avoidance and then finally the
third one is that that we have
incomplete physical understanding of the
universe so if I see a new phenomena
which by agent style is a good example
of that we saw this new phenomena of
these strange dips we've never seen
before
it was hypothesized immediately this
could be aliens it's like a god of the
gaps but it turned out to be incomplete
physical understanding and so that that
happens all the time in the first Pulsar
that was discovered
same story
um Jocelyn Bell kind of somewhat uh
tongue-in-cheek called it little green
man one because it looked a lot like the
radio signature that was expected from a
civilization but of course it turned out
to be a completely new type of star that
we had never seen before which was a
neutron star
um with these two Jets coming out the
top of it and so
um that's a challenge those three things
are really really difficult in terms of
experimental design for a scientist to
work around something that can explain
anything can avoid anything so it's
almost unforcifiable and could always
just be to some degree as you said we
have this very limited knowledge of the
infinite possibilities of physical law
and we're probably only scratching the
surface
each time and we've seen it so often in
history we may just be detecting some
new phenomena well that last one
I think I'm a little more okay with
making mistakes on yeah which is because
it's exciting still but because no
matter so you might exaggerate the
importance of the discovery but the
whole point
is to try to find stuff in this world
that's weird and try to characterize
that weirdness sure you can throw a
little green man as a label on it but
eventually
it like it's as mysterious and as
beautiful as interesting as little
agreement like we we tend to think that
there's some kind of threshold but like
there's all kinds of weird organisms on
this Earth that operate very differently
than humans that are super interesting
uh the human mind is super interesting I
mean like uh weirdness and complexity
is
is as interesting in any of its forms as
what we might think from Hollywood what
aliens are so like that that's that's
okay looking for weirdness is on Mars
okay that's one of the best sales
pitchers to do tennis signature work is
that you know we always have that as our
fullback that look we're going to look
for alien signatures if we fail we're
gonna discover some awesome new physics
along the way and so even a uh any kind
of signature that we detect is always
going to be interesting
um and so that that compels us to
um have not only the question of looking
for life in the universe but it can it
gives us a strong scientific grounding
as to why this sort of research should
be funded and should be executed because
it always pushes the Frontiers knowledge
I wonder if we'll be able to discover
and be open enough
to a broad definition of aliens where we
see some kind of techno signature
basically like a touring test like this
thing is intelligent like it's
processing information in a very
interesting way but but you can say that
about chemistry you could say that about
physics
maybe not physics chemistry like
interesting complex chemistry you could
say that this is processing this is
storing information this is propagating
information over time so I mean I want I
it's a gray area between a living
organism that we would call an alien and
a thing that's super interesting is able
to carry some kind of intelligence yeah
information is a really useful way to
frame what we're looking for though
because it then you'll then you're
divorced from making assumptions about
even a civilization necessarily or
anything like that so any kind of
information signature indeed you can
take things like the light curve from
Biogen star and ask what is the minimum
number of free parameters or the minimum
information content that must be encoded
within the slight curve and the hope is
that maybe from you know a good example
be from a radio signature you just text
something that has you know a thousand
megabytes of of parameters essentially
contained within it that's pretty
clearly at that point not the product of
a natural process or it's any natural
process that we could possibly imagine
with our current understanding of the
universe and so thinking even if we
can't decode which actually I'm
skeptical would be able to ever decode
it in our lifetimes it would probably
take decades to fully ever figure out
what they're trying to tell us but if
there was a message there we could at
least know that there is a high
information content and there is
complexity and that this is a attempt at
communication information transfer and
leave it to our subsequent generations
to figure out what exactly it is they're
trying to say
what again a wild question and thank you
for uh uh entertaining them entertaining
them I really really appreciate it
um but what kind of signal in our
lifetime what kind of thing do you think
might happen
could possibly happen
where the scientific Community would be
convinced that there's alien
civilizations out there like what uh she
already said maybe a strong infrared
signature for something like a Dyson
Sphere yeah that's possible that that's
also to some degree a little bit
ambiguous
um because that's the challenge starting
to interrupt is where
your brain would be like you as a
scientist would be like I know it's
ambiguous but this is really weird yeah
I think
if he had some I can imagine something
like a prime number sequence
or a mathematical sequence like the
Fibonacci series something being
broadcast radically provable that this
is not a physical phenomenon right I
mean yeah prime numbers is a pretty good
case because there's no natural
phenomena that produces prime number
sequences it seems to be a purely an
abstract mathematical concept as far as
I'm aware and so if we detected uh you
know if she was a radio Blitz that were
following that sequence it would be
pretty clear to me or it could even be
uh you know cast that you can suggested
that Pi could be encoded in that or you
might use the hydrogen line but multiply
by pi like some very specific uh
frequency of the universe like a
hydrogen line but multiply it by a
abstract mathematical constant that
would imply strongly that there was
someone behind the scenes operating that
um as sorry stored in which phenomena
though there's a thing of a radio wave
but the information I mean we kind of
toyed with this um
uh idea in a video I did about
hypothetical civilization on my channel
but one kind of fun way I do want to
bring the this conversation towards time
a little bit and thinking about
um not just looking for life and
intelligence around us right now but
looking into the past and even into the
future to some degree or communicating
with the future and so we had this fun
experiment of imagining a civilization
that was born at the beginning of the
history of the Galaxy and being the
first and what it would be like for them
and they were desperately searching for
evidence of life but couldn't find it
and so they decided to try and leave
something behind for future
civilizations to discover to tell them
about themselves but of course a radio
signage is not going to work there
because it has have a power source and
that's a piece of Machinery it's going
to eventually break down it's gonna be
hard to maintain that for billions of
years time scale and so you wanted
something that was kind of passive that
doesn't require an energy source but can
somehow transmit information which is
hard to think about something that
satisfies those criteria but there was a
proposal by one of my colleagues Connor
which inspired a lot of us in techno
signatures and he suggested that you
could build artificial transiters so you
could be build sheets of material that
transit in front of the star maybe one
thin sheet passes across first then two
then three then five and seven so you
could follow the prime number sequence
of these and so there'd be a clear
indication that someone had manufactured
those but they don't require any energy
source because they're just sheets of
material in orbit of the star they would
eventually degrade from micrometeorites
so maybe their orbits would become
destabilized but they should have
lifetimes far exceeding the lifetime of
any uh battery or mechanical electronic
system that we could at least without
energy conceive of building and so you
can imagine an extending that and how
could you encode not just a prime number
sequence but maybe in the spatial
pattern of this very complex light curve
we see you could encode more and more
information through 2D shapes and the
way those occupations happen and maybe
uh you could even encode uh messages and
and in-depth information from you know
you could even imagine it being like a a
lower layer of information which is just
the prime number sequence but then you
look closely and you see the smaller
divots embedded within those that have a
deeper layer of information to extract
um and so to me something like that
would be pretty compelling that that was
somebody who would mind if unless it's
just a a very impressive hoax that would
be a pretty compelling evidence in this
civilization and actually the methods of
um astronomy right now are kind of
marching towards
being able to better and better detect a
signal like that yeah I mean to some
degree it's just building bigger
aperture in Space the bigger the
telescope the the finer ability to
detach those mining signals do you think
the current sort of the scientific
Community another weird question but
just the observations that are happening
now do you think they're ready for a
prime number sequence in in the um so if
if we're using the the current method
the transit timing variation method like
do you think
you're ready do you have the tools to
detect the prime number sequence
yeah for sure I mean there's
200 000 stars that Kepler monitored and
it monitor them all the time it took a
photo of each one of them every 30
minutes measure their brightness and it
did that for four and a half years and
so you have already and Tess is doing it
right now another mission and so you
have already an existing catalog and
people are uh genuinely scouring through
each of those light curves with
automated machine learning techniques or
even developed some on our own team that
can look for weird Behavior we wrote a
code called the weird detector for
instance the of course you know it was
just the most generic thing possible let
don't assume anything about the signal
shape just look for anything that
repeats the distinguish rate can be
anything can we kind of learn the
template of the signal from the data
itself and then we it's like a template
matching filter to see if that repeats
many many times in the data and so we
actually applied that and found a bunch
of interesting stuff but we didn't see
anything that was the prime number
sequence at least on the Kepler data
that's 200 000 Stars which sounds like a
lot but compared to you 200 billion
stars in the Milky Way it's really just
scratching the surface so one because
there could be something much more
generalizable than the prime number
sequence it's ultimately the question of
a signal that's very difficult to
compress
in the general
sensible compressed means so maybe as we
get better and better machine learning
methods that automatically figure out
analyze the data to to understand how to
compress it just you'll be able to
discover data that's for some reason
it's not compressible
but then you know compression really is
a bottomless pit because like that's
really what intelligence is is being
able to compress information yeah and to
some degree the more you I would imagine
I don't work in compression algorithms
but I would imagine the more you
compress your signal
um the the more assumptions that kind of
go on behalf of the decoder the more
skilled they really have to be you know
some of the a prime number sequence is
completely unencoded information
essentially but um if you look at the
Arecibo message
they were fairly careful with their
pixelation of this simple uh image they
sent to try and
make it as interpretable as possible to
be that even a dumb alien would be able
to figure out what we're trying to show
them here because there's all sorts of
conventions and rules that are built in
that we we tend to presume when we
design our messages and so if your
message is assuming they know how to do
an MP3 decoder particular compression
algorithm I'm sure they could eventually
reverse engineer it and figure it out
but you're you're making it harder for
them to get to that point so maybe I
always think you probably would have a
two-tier system right you'd probably
have some lower tier key system and then
maybe beneath that you'd have a deeper
compressed layer of more in-depth
information